PRIMARIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AFTER A LECTURE BREAKING NEWS WE
WILL BRING YOU RESULTS AS WE GET
THEM INTIMATE.
BUT FIRST WE WANT TO TAKE YOU
BACK 48 HOURS.
NEW YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL ERIC
SCHNEIDERMAN WAS THE BIG DEAL
THEN IN WIDELY RESPECTED
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL.
A FEMINIST ICON WHO WAS REGARDED
BY MANY AS A POTENTIAL
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE.
THERE'S NOT A PROGRESSIVE CROSS
THAT ERIC SCHNEIDERMAN DIDN'T
EMBRACE WHOLEHEARTEDLY AND THEN
IN TIME TO IMPOSE BY FOREST ON
THE PEOPLE OF NEW YORK STATE.
SCHNEIDERMAN WAS AN ALL-PURPOSE
LEFT-WING ACTIVIST.
HE WAS ESPECIALLY AN AGGRESSIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE #MeToo
MOVEMENT, WATCH.
>> THE CHALLENGES FACING THESE
SURVIVORS ARE PART OF A LARGER
SYSTEM OF DISCRIMINATION AND
REALLY A MANIFESTATION OF A
CULTURE OF MALE SUPREMACY.